-I love that you're here
on Halloween, for many reasons.
Just,
I'm just happy you're here.
But also, you must run into
versions of you...
-Yeah.
-...a lot...
[ Laughter ]
-Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
-...on Halloween.
How does one react when --
-I mean, just --
You know,
give a positive review.
Don't -- you know.
-Yeah, I'm hoping, yes.
-Yeah, no.
I'm not gonna, like,
give them notes
or critique them in any way.
Yeah, and it is, like --
it's -- it's a lovely thing.
My friends send me photos
of their friends' kids
or their kids, like,
dressed up as Potter.
And, yeah, it's awesome.
-When you --
When you were a child,
doing Harry,
and seeing other kids as Harry,
was that odd -- more --
Was that weird?
-I guess.
Like -- but I think I was
probably saved from that lot by,
like, how sort of tragically
non-existent Halloween was
in England growing up
when I was there.
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't even a big deal,
right?
-Not really.
Like, I've never been
trick-or-treating in my life,
which people regard
as I've been neglected,
but I'm fine.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah.
And so, I don't think --
Yeah, it's never been, like,
as much of a --
of a thing for me.
But now --
now, lots of Harry's
running around, yeah.
-Yeah, it's good.
You're in the middle
of rehearsals right now.
You returning to the theater.
-Yeah.
-We're very excited about this.
-Thank you. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm terrified.
-We love you. You're doing
all the cool things.
-Thank you.
-I love these choices.
What is this you're doing?
-Yes, it's a musical called
"Merrily We Roll Along,"
which some will know
and others may not.
[ Cheers ]
It's a Sondheim show.
It's one of --
I've seen this production
in London many years ago,
and it's one of the best things
I've ever seen.
So now I get to be a part
of doing it here,
which is very intimidating
but great.
-Stephen Sondheim.
Yeah, this is a --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I read about this.
They -- They revived it in --
in London and won all these
awards and all this stuff.
-Yeah.
-So now you're bringing it
back here.
-So, we're bringing it here
with the same director
who did it in London,
Maria Friedman,
who's just incredible.
And the show is -- is amazing.
It's incredibly complicated.
And, you know,
I've done one musical before,
but there were a lot of less,
like, five-part harmonies for me
to be involved in in that.
But, yeah, I'm learning.
Yeah.
-That's awesome. You're --
you're co-starring
with Jonathan Groff.
-Yeah, Jonathan Groff
and Lindsay Mendez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Who I -- I could not wish
for a better two people.
And, like, professionals
and talented people
but also human beings
to do this with.
So I'm very, very lucky
to be working with them.
-Yeah, good man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Previews -- Previews begin
November 21st.
-Oh, my God!
-It opens December 12th.
Oh, he's like -- yeah.
-That's terrifying.
-Yeah, don't leave right now.
Stay here.
-And it opens December 12th
at New York Theatre Workshop.
Everyone should check that out.
Let's talk about --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story."
Finally, we can talk about this.
-Yes!
-It's out on Friday.
-Yeah, I'm so excited
for people to see it.
-The reviews are amazing.
Congrats on all
the great buzz around this.
-I know. Thank you.
-You play Al.
-You play Weird Al.
-Yeah, I know.
-When you first heard
that Weird Al wanted you
for this role,
what went through your head?
-I mean, I knew Al --
Not personally,
but I knew his work.
I knew who he was.
So, when I got the e-mail
being like,
"You've been offered the part
of Al Yankovic in
'The Al Yankovic Story,'"
I was like, "I mean,
I'm very flattered,
but there are, surely,
other people that are closer,
physically, to Al or to --"
[ Laughter ]
You know, and sort of had
all that reaction.
-You look nothing like Weird Al.
-Right!
-At all.
-And, you know,
there's only about
4 foot between us.
[ Laughter ]
And so, like --
But then,
as soon as I was reading --
Honestly, as soon as I opened
the first page of the script,
I was like, "Oh, right. Okay.
I get what the joke is.
Accuracy is not the point here.
We're doing something else
entirely."
[ Laughter ]
And at -- at that point,
I was like, "Oh, I can do
this version of Al."
And it was -- it was so evident
from just reading the script
what a great, fun thing
this would be to do.
It's, like, six songs
and two action sequences
and, like, insane scenes
that you get to do.
Yes, so it was a very easy yes.
-Yeah.
What was it like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait till you see it.
It's so fun.
What's it like playing Weird Al
in front of Al?
'Cause I'm assuming
he was on set?
-Yes, he was.
He was there every day.
I think it was, honestly,
stranger for him than me
just because we are acting out
this, like,
Bizarro World version
of parts of his life.
And, also,
a weird thing happened.
It's impossible.
I use the word "weird"
so much anyway.
-I know.
I thought about that.
I thought about that
when talking about this.
I'm like, "Is it weird
to say 'weird' in Weird Al?"
-No, it's not.
-I'm like --
-It's our only option.
-Yes, it is!
We need another option
for the word "weird."
-But so, we -- I --
The thing happen on film sets,
which you know
where you get called
by your character name a lot.
So, on set, I was referred to
over the walkie-talkie and stuff
as "Weird Al."
And then,
they needed something else
to call Weird Al, so he ended up
being called "Real Al,"
which after having crafted
a persona for like 40 years,
it's probably really annoying
to be stripped of it
on your first day on a film set.
-Yes!
You're like, "I worked
my whole life to be Weird Al,
and now I'm Real --
Real Al Yankovic?"
-I'm Weird Al now.
Yeah.
-Now you're Weird Al
and he's Real Al.
Did he ever pull you aside and
go, "I wouldn't do it that way.
I acted this way"?
-As you know, the version of Al
that I'm playing in the film
is so --
It's, at times, like the real Al
but it is, at times,
so far from that, that that
wasn't really a concern.
His main -- the thing he cared
about the most, I think,
even in an insane version
of a biopic,
was that he not look terrible
at playing the instrument
that he is famous for playing.
And so most of his notes
were accordion-based.
But most of it was,
particularly, about how much
I am pumping the bellows.
I was not pumping enough.
[ Laughter ]
And so, I -- many of the notes
were just him being --
'Cause, you know,
which is fair enough.
You don't want to look crap
at playing the thing
you're famous for being good at.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And, actually, it's not you
singing in the movie.
It's Al's voice.
-Yes, absolutely. Yeah.
-That was a choice
that you made. You go --
-Yeah, we wanted --
one of the many sort of
musical biopic tropes we wanted
to take the piss out of
was the --
clearly a different voice
coming out of the actor's head.
[ Laughter ]
So that's why -- that's what --
I sang along on set,
but, no, it's all Al
and everything.
-Evan Rachel Wood
plays Madonna in this.
-Right.
-By the way, she's phenomenal.
-Spectacular in this film.
-Like, phenomenal.
She's so funny.
And she can sing in real life.
-Yes, she can.
-She sang on our show.
-Yes, I know.
Yeah, well, so --
The day after
we finished shooting,
we had, like, a very small
wrap party at a karaoke place.
And Evan got up and sang,
and me and the director
were just
looking at each other like,
"Why haven't we got her
to sing in the movie?
This is -- This is the stupidest
thing that we're --"
'Cause she is --
I mean, I can, like, sing.
She can sing.
-Sing.
She's fantastic.
-Yeah.
Her doing karaoke is truly
a thing to behold.
-Before we show a clip,
is there anything
you want to say
to set up the movie?
-Yeah, just that it's
the 100% historically accurate
and unassailably true story
of the life
of Weird Al Yankovic.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Daniel Radcliffe in
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story."
Take a look at this.
-Whoo!
♪ My, my, my Sharona ♪
Whoo!
-♪ My, my, my bologna ♪
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Al?
[ Suspenseful music ]
-♪ My, my, my bologna ♪
♪♪
♪ My, my, my bologna ♪
-You okay?
♪♪
♪ Ooh, my little hungry one ♪
♪ Hungry one ♪
♪ Open up a package
of my bologna ♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
A legend is born!
Daniel Radcliffe, everyone!
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story"
is available for free,
exclusively on the Roku Channel
this Friday.
Winston Duke joins us next.
Stick around, everybody.